hallo ich befinde mich gerade in
schweden um eines der verrücktesten und
hälfte der gesamten welt aus zu checken
es ist nicht nur eines der verrücktesten
hotels der ganzen welt sondern eins das
auch nur einmal in komplett europa gibt
ich werde heute mitten auf dem see für
eine nacht unter wasser ich wäre für
dieses video fasst mal nach dubai
geflogen wo es auch ein hotel unter
wasser in einem aquarium gibt aber dies
hier ist ein bisschen spezieller denn es
ist mitten auf dem see was es zu bieten
hat wie viel das kostet wie wir dorthin
kommen und alles weitere erfahrt ihr in
diesem video
[Musik]
ich bin gerade in schweden weil wir bis
gestern sein größtes weil gedreht haben
was komplett verrückt waren eine super
neue erfahrung und alles dazu seht ihr
ab november bei fritz weineck auf dem
kanal heute haben einen tag frei und ich
dachte ich nutze den direkt um ein
bisschen content für euch mitzunehmen
und um mehr in der nacht in diesem unter
wasser hotel zu können ich warte jetzt
darauf dass mein boot taxi kommt mich
auf den see bringt und dann geht's
weiter
okay das hotel wurde vor 20 jahren aufs
meer gebracht ob man das sieht ob es
renoviert wurde oder in welchem zustand
das ist werden wir auch gemeinsam
herausgeben
oh mein gott da ist
das wird meine unterkunft für die nacht
leisten
dafür ist meine gastgeberin in der sonne
weg richtung stadt und wir schauen uns
gemeinsam das hotel an
so sieht das ganze hier von draußen aus
wir haben als aller erstes mal eine
terrasse quasi ein penthouse
[Musik]
geht es nämlich komplett einmal außen
rum werden wir hier rum gehen haben wir
hier ein paar stühle ein tisch den kann
man es natürlich hinstellen wo auch
immer wir wollen damit wir gleich im
sonnenuntergang sitzen ohne uns herum
kleine inseln andere boote hier vorne
haben wir die stadt west daraus keine
ahnung ob das richtig ist aber der ist
zumindestens start und jetzt schauen sie
rein und gucken was das ding von drinnen
so zu bieten hat also wir haben hier auf
dieser ebene einen raum auf den wir zu
unserer rechten direkt neben dem eingang
den küchenbereich haben wenn wir zu
unserer linken schwenken dann haben wir
ein klo wir haben soweit ich das hier
sehe keine dusche aber wasser um uns
herum genug dann haben wir hier drüber
dann geht es hier über zu gläsern tassen
darüber unsere köpfe ein bisschen salz
und standard kam das büro ist schon
ziemlich am wackeln das muss ich schon
sagen deswegen sind hier oben in den
schrank auf 70 bild drin wenn ich mir
heute nacht also ein bisschen zu wacklig
wird dann werden wir darauf
zurückgreifen müssen unter mir geht es
direkt weiter zu dem eigentlich
wichtigen part meinem schlafzimmer und
dafür gehen wir diese klappe hier ist
ziemlich schwer
[Musik]
da war es gar nicht so viel wie gedacht
hätte wir befinden uns zirka fünf meter
unter wasser wir haben fenster in alle
richtungen und zwei betten so sieht das
zimmer in der totalen aus komplett
kosten die scheiben könnten ruhig ein
bisschen sauberer sein aber es klar ist
dass jetzt keine schnelle ist an die
macht super einfach dran kommt das bin
ich nur gespannt ob wir auch fische
sehen können ja aber an und für sich
ziemlich krass und spürt man dass
gewackelt auf jeden fall deutlich
weniger
hallo
hallo minister wer kostet 2000 wie viel
das ganze kostet sage ich euch später
gibt es nämlich sinn macht und ob das im
verhältnis steht kann ich erst sagen
wenn ich das hier wirklich richtig
erlebt habe weil ganz im ernst sowie die
räumlichkeiten jetzt bisher aussehen
passt das nicht so ganz zusammen
ein bisschen was habe ich eingekauft
denn hier gibt es natürlich keinen hut
oder ähnliches hier gibt es auch kein
restaurant das hier in refrath ich muss
selber kochen und darum kümmern muss
jetzt
das essen wurde nicht bestellt ist kam
nicht vom service aber es hat eine menge
spaß gemacht das selber zu machen und
wir haben diese aussicht für das
abendessen und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich habe lange schon nicht mehr
selber gekocht das hotel hat mich jetzt
quasi darein gezwungen und ich bin super
happy und jetzt lasse ich mir erstmal
schmecken und genießen den
sonnenuntergang
ist wirklich richtig manchmal so
komplett weg von allem zu sein und
alleine zu sein um 1 100 ernst war hier
kann auch niemand kommen und wenn ich
hier nicht auf meine nachrichten
antworte dann bin ich komplett
abgeschafft und halt niemals alleine in
den urlaub fahren aber jetzt wo ich mal
alleine unterwegs war oder jetzt wieder
allein unterwegs bin das tut schon
richtig gut schon jetzt ist nichts neues
die sonne ist so langsam komplett
untergegangen das bedeutet für uns
schlafen gehen und endlich die
eigentliche quintessenz dieses
hotelzimmers ausprobieren ich bin super
gespannt wie die nacht wird
das runter
[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen in meinem
schlafzimmer für heute nacht als
nächstes aber erst mal probe liegen das
hat er so jugendherbergen flair
natürlich ist es schade dass wir jetzt
in der nacht wo man eigentlich am
meisten zeit im bett oder im
schlafzimmer verbringt nicht rauskommen
können aber wie auch es ist eben dunkel
ja jetzt gerade noch gesehen dass sie
extra eine taschenlampe steht leer und
damit gute nacht aus fünf metern tiefe
eines schwedischen 66 den speck der ich
habe unheimlich schlecht geschlafen
das ist mir jetzt langsam so wirklich
ein bisschen fehlt wenn die fische und
irgendwas was sich irgendwie sehen kann
also ist schön dass ich unter wasser bin
alles passiert hat nichts mit scheiben
dreckig aber bei einem unterwasser hotel
hätte ich mir wirklich etwas anderes
vorgestellt viel mehr irgendwas wo man
die unterwasserwelt so ein bisschen
entdecken kann wo es sich so ein
bisschen anfühlt wie es tauchen aber das
hier ist er mal
kommen wir zur bewertung zimmer es fehlt
strom es fehlt eine dusche und ansonsten
hat man eigentlich alles da wir hatten
genug platz auf jeden fall für eine
person zu zweit finden acht wunderbar
gewesen aber ich hätte mir ein bisschen
mehr modernität erhofft auf der anderen
seite natürlich cool so eine treppe
mitten im raum die dann nach unten führt
das war schon wirklich ein erlebnis der
360° balkon außenrum war auch wunderbar
mann ist komplett abgetrennt von allen
anderen leuten absoluter traum deswegen
klingt das ganze von mir eine sieben von
zehn man muss das ganze in relation sind
ich würde das gar nicht mehr als hotel
bewerten sondern vielmehr als pension
auf die ein bisschen geachtet wird weil
der einem die schlüssel übergeben werden
aber so was wie service ist halt super
schwer zu bewerten klar man wird
hingefahren aber ansonsten lässt der
service zu wünschen übrig es ist eben
kein hotel deswegen habe ich mich dafür
entschieden genau die mitte zu geben 15
verpflegung war mir von vornherein
bewusst ich muss mir die sachen selber
mitbringen mit ein bisschen planung
alles bestens habe ich alles mitgebracht
das problem natürlich bringe ich jetzt
kein eigenes scharfes messer mit oder
keine eigenen großen löffel was man mit
einem kleinen löffel essen von diesen
sachen gibts hier in diesem hotelzimmer
wirklich eine menge und das gilt so ein
bisschen an vielen punkten den spaß muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen das hat jetzt
viel mehr noch was mit zimmer und
ausstattung zu tun aber irgendwie hat es
mich beim essen am allermeisten gestellt
deswegen bekommt das ganze von mir eine
sechs von zehn bei genau die sachen
gefehlt haben sich am dringendsten
gebraucht sauberkeit lässt zu wünschen
übrig fünf von zehn das ganze war
einfach wirklich ein super vielen
stellen nicht besonders sauber und hat
so gewirkt als würden nur einmal schnell
irgendwie die bettlaken getauscht und
ansonsten würde sich da nicht so richtig
darum gekümmert preis leistung endlich
kann ich darauf eingehen wie viel ich
für diese nacht bezahlt habt ihr habt
gehört an wie vielen stellen das
eigentlich nicht so richtig funktioniert
hat und deswegen raus ist mich um so
mehr zu sagen dass ich für diese nacht
klar die experience ich war komplett
alleine und das hat sich auch gesund
aber 350 euro finde ich schon deutlich
zu heftig glaube sind in skandinavien
schweden das preisniveau ist einfach ein
anderes aber für mich oder euch ist das
eigentlich nichts und ich würde euch
schon ein bisschen davon abraten mit
wegen ich auf weniger als 5 von 10 gehen
muss und ich glaube das ist ne vier von
zehn
euro die nacht da kriegst du halt nach
massagen fünf sterne zimmer noch
frühstück das stimmt es ist eine drei
von zehn nach begründung meines katers
leo liebe grüße leben viele große löffel
kein scharfes messer eine taschenlampe
für die keine batterien da sind und kein
schlauchboot mitten auf dem see sind
alles sachen die mich denken lassen ok
jemand hatte eine super gute idee vor 20
jahren und das wird sich einfach nicht
mehr so richtig gut darum gekümmert ich
meine würde der besitzer auch nur eine
nacht in dieser pension schlafen würde
ich ihn sofort auffallen welche sachen
fehlen und wo sachen zu verbessern gibt
aber das ist anscheinend seit 20 jahren
nicht mehr passiert und damit endet
meine nacht im unterwasser hotel
offiziell
ich weiß dann wird zum video haben sich
einige leute beschwert wie ich die preis
leistung vom teuren hotel bewertet habe
ich probiere mich jetzt immer weiter
anzupassen und das genauer zu machen er
denkt das hotel hätte anders bewertet
sein müssen oder wenn ich einfach
bewerten wollt dann tut das in den
kommentaren ich werde ein bisschen
durchschauen und gucken wie ihr das
bewährte macht's gut das war das
donnerstags video für diese woche
vergesst nicht sorgen ihren am sonntag
ein weiteres video und nächste woche
kommt ein video in dem ich fake aufgaben
habe das war es wir sehen uns ja
[Musik]